the movie opens with a high school
student Patty bladel who is constantly
bullied for being overweight and is
nicknamed fatty Patty she narrates
herself as one of the girls who spends
most of the time at home while the other
girls of her age are out losing their
virginity Patty does have a crush on her
handsome classmate brick Armstrong but
she doesn't have the guts to ask him out
she does however have the Common Sense
on the other hand we are introduced to
Brick's father Bob Armstrong a local
civil rights lawyer who ALS also coaches
beauty pageant contestants one fine day
at work Bob is seen coaching a teen
named Dixie who is a bit immature when
it comes to politics her immaturity
causes her to lose the beauty
competition which enrages her mother
Regina she then threatens Bob to return
her money which the latter refuses as a
result she walks up to the stage and
accuses him of molesting her daughter
shocking everyone this incident causes
him to be disgraced which results in his
career taking a downturn as nobody wants
to to work with him anymore one day
Patty and her best friend Nanie go to a
convenience store where they
coincidentally spot brick despite
Patty's hesitance Nani approaches brick
on her behalf and asks him out for a
date however the ladder turns down the
proposal and walks away from there later
the heartbroken Patty is sitting outside
the store when she is approached by a
homeless man who insults her weight in a
fit of rage she punches him in the face
only to get punched back causing her to
end up in the hospital with a broken jaw
3 months later we see Patty who has lost
a lot of weight thanks to a liquid diet
in the hospital as a result she is now
thin and beautiful with confidence like
never before however there is a problem
she is being prosecuted for assaulting
the homeless man in order to handle
their case pro bono Patty and her mother
try to approach several lawyers but no
one seems to be willing to take their
case eventually they enlist the help of
Bob who accepts the case after being
jobless for more than 3 months in the
next scene Bob visits Patty's house to
gather some details regarding the case
but she isn't home as a result he talks
to her mother Angie who briefs him about
the incident she also shows him the
pictures of Patty who used to be fat at
that time Bob doesn't appear to be much
interested in the case so he simply
decides to go with the plea agreement
strategy but once he meets Patty he is
so mesmerized by her beauty that he
ditches his earlier idea and plans to
argue self-defense he then begins
training for the court and also helps
her improve her appearance to look more
innocent moreover Patty also seduces the
cashier from the store Donald who is the
only witness of the incident meanwhile
Regina who is jealous of Bob getting a
job hires a spy to tail him so that she
can defame him again one evening the
beauty contest winner named Magnolia
summons Bob to her place in order to
help her finalize a dress during this
the girl changes her clothes in front of
Bob making him feel uneasy unbeknownst
to them this moment is captured by the
spy who sends the picture to Regina on
the day of the trial Donald as expected
claims to have no recollection of the
incident Patty then successfully
convinces the judge that her actions
were in self-defense finally securing a
victory over the case despite this she
is not satisfied yet as she wants
revenge against all of those who have
ever been mean to her Bob tells her that
the best revenge is a life well lived he
then suggests that she participate in
the beauty pageant because a stunning
girl like her can have her shot as the
next missusa however Angie opposes the
idea concerned about the potential
sexualization and objectification of her
daughter later on Patty and Nani join
Angie's Alcoholics Anonymous support
meeting where they unexpectedly meet JN
the same homeless man who previously
punched Patty fueled by anger she
decides to seek revenge by making him
fall in love with her and then rejecting
him following this she approaches him
and takes him to a hotel room with the
intention of seducing him however the
man gets so Dr drunk that he falls
asleep without doing anything infuriated
that she lost her chance she grabs an
alcohol bottle and pours it in the bed
with the intention of burning it all
down but at the same time she recalls
Bob's earlier suggestion about the
beauty pageants so she promptly calls
him and says she's interested despite
her mother's disapproval the next
morning Patty wakes up with no memory of
the drunken night that has passed she
plans to skip school because she is
still not ready to face the bullies she
goes to Bob and requests that he start
training her for the beauty pageant
however he urges her to attend school
first as it is also important for her
personality development following this
Patty arrives at school but her
classmates don't recognize her due to
her transformed appearance she now
decides to use her Newfound Beauty to
exact revenge on those who tormented her
and sets her first Target on her former
Crush brick however Magnolia intervenes
and warns her to stay away from brick
asserting that he is her boyfriend later
in Spanish class Patty learns the news
of a man's critical condition following
a hotel fire the same place where she
was last night fearing that she might be
responsible she confides the incident
and her best friend who then leaves the
school to investigate Nani arrives at
the hospital where she finds the
homeless guy being treated just then she
is approached by her cop father who is
coincidentally in charge of the case she
asks him about the culprit but all he
can say is that the homeless guy was
with a girl in the meantime Patty is
having lunch alone in the school
cafeteria when she's approached by a new
hot student Christian Patty is
immediately attracted to him but before
she can talk to him she receives a text
from Nani confirming her suspicion in a
state of panic Patty calls Bob and
confides everything in him Bob who sees
Patty as his only chance to return to
the pageant World vows to prove her
innocence while he investigates the
hotel room Patty and Nani visit Donald
to retrace the events of the previous
night turns out that Patty had visited
his store that night to buy some snacks
he discloses that she was so drunk that
she flashed him and wasn't wearing a bra
hearing this she recalls that she had
left her bra in the hotel room realizing
that she might be caught due to this
evidence Patty uses Nani's police
connection to sneak into the evidence
room to get her bra back shortly after
Bob calls her to inform that stealing
the evidence isn't sufficient
emphasizing the need for a solid Alibi
as Witnesses saw her with John during
check-in Patty and Nani then returned to
Donald seeking assistance in
manipulating the security footage from
the previous night they decide to
reenact the events in order to make a
new tape for this they proceed to make
Patty heavily drunk however their plan
becomes a total failure when Patty
becomes excessively drunk and collapses
she ends up in the same hospital where
JN is receiving treatment at this point
another shocking Revelation unfolds
Regina who had accused Bob of molesting
her daughter is having a secret affair
with his underage son brick in the next
scene Bob visits the hospital to check
on the homeless man but is astonished to
find Patty wandering the Halls he
hastily advises her to stay in her room
to avoid being recognized by Jon despite
this warning the mischievous Patty Peaks
into Jon's room and gets caught in the
process thankfully at the same time Bob
manages to figure out the entire
situation and begins explaining
according to him Jon woke up that night
and ignited a match stick to light his
cigarette which caused the fire but he
blamed Patty in order to exonerate
himself to everyone's surprise Jon
confirms this account making everyone
happy before departing from the hospital
Patty confronts Jon one last time to
reveal that she's the same fat girl whom
he had previously assaulted she then
expresses a wish for his death and
miraculously JN succumbs to a heart
attack bringing a sense of satisfaction
to Patty what the hell is the moral of
this story a few days later Bob decides
to take Patty to the Miss bearback
Buckaroo pageant in Alabama in order to
visit his former mentor Stella Rose
Buckley here we learned that it was
Stella who helped him enter the world of
pageant coaching in the late '90s Bob's
wife Coral Le isn't on board with his
decision as she believes it is a risky
move due to the previous accusation
however Bob stresses the necessity of
this move asserting that Patty is his
only client capable of restoring his
tarnished reputation in the pageant
industry after packing up her belongings
the excited Patty arrives at Bob's house
and the two set off towards Alabama
after a long and joyful Drive they reach
the Miss bearback Buckaroo pageant where
they are received by Stella upon
introducing one another Stella instructs
her student Roxy to escort Patty to the
hotel room while she talks to Bob during
their conversation Bob mentions Patty's
high potential to become Miss USA but he
struggling to coach her properly due to
her mischievous Behavior hearing this
Stella advises him to be more stringent
in his approach just like she is with
her students on the other hand Nani who
is concerned about her best friend
approaches Donald at the convenience
store and requests that he accompany her
to Alabama Dixie who happens to be in
the same store overhears their
conversation and decides to tag along as
she seems to have some unfinished
business with Bob the trio then hits the
road making their way to Alabama in
Dixie's Jeep meanwhile Coral plans a
dinner party at a residence to invite
her affluent friends however her plans
are thwarted by an unwelcome visit from
her trailer trash sister Branda Lan and
her kids forcing her to cancel the
dinner plan back in Alabama Bob and
Stella team up to train Patty on how to
walk and how to behave throughout the
training session Bob assigns her with
various chores as a part of the training
which she reluctantly complies with at
one point he leaves Patty alone to train
which Stella sees as a perfect
opportunity to manipulate the girl she
then attempts to sway Patty to her side
by highlighting negative aspects of Bob
she asserts that he's exploiting her for
self-benefit and will eventually abandon
her just like he did to her 20 years ago
though turns out that Stella is
intending to seek revenge against Bob
for leaving her heartbroken in the past
unbeknownst to them Bob is eavesdropping
on their conversation from a distance
before Stella can brainwash her further
he steps in and takes her away after
this the two head to a restaurant for
lunch and by this point Patty starts
harboring suspicions about Bob as they
Converse she complains about not
learning anything related to the beauty
pageant in an effort to prove her wrong
Bob instructs her to do a ramp walk the
Patty's surprise she realizes is that
all the chores he assigned her were
indeed part of her training
significantly improving her walk now Bob
is like Mr Miagi bikini waxs on bikini
waxs off this changes her perception of
Bob and she begins developing romantic
feelings for him despite being aware of
his marital status later that day Bob
confronts Stella about what he overheard
earlier evading the topic she talks
about how much she missed him after he
left she also expresses that she still
loves him and tries to kiss him however
Bob who feels very uneasy fleas the
scene he returns back to a room only to
be startled by Patty who also tries to
seduce him frustrated by everything he's
going through he throws her out of his
room seeking some time alone devastated
Patty then goes to a bar with Stella and
Roxy for some drinks amidst this Stella
clicks a selfie with Patty and secretly
sends it to Bob raising his concern as a
result he hastily gets in his car and
rushes to the bar meanwhile Patty
happens to see Stella's message on her
phone which makes her realize that both
she and Bob are just using her upset by
the betrayals she opts to enter a
crawfish eating contest contemplating
giving up on her diet Midway through the
contest Bob arrives and tries to stop
her from eating more however she refuses
to listen and continues eating Bob then
admits that he was once overweight like
her so he genuinely empathizes with her
struggle still suspicious Patty tells
him to prove it by eating the croads and
winning the contest determined to earn
her trust by Bob begins eating and
eventually wins the competition this
pivotal moment finally Bridges the gap
between the two of them and Patty
promises to do anything he says in the
aftermath Bob confronts Stella who
ultimately reveals that she has been
coaching Roxy for missusa now that she
knows everything about Patty's
vulnerabilities including her feelings
for Bob she vows to defeat him and Lead
Roxy to Victory before departing she
gives Patty an engraved necklace that
Bob gave to her as proof of their Affair
saying you know what to do Patty soon
realizes that this necklace is a weapon
to break Bob's marriage and gain full
control over him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching